okay so let's look at the different
components of an email first we have our
subject line this should be short and
draw attention to your email you're
trying to engage the customer enough
that they want to open the email this is
setting the expectation for the contents
of the email if you're promoting a new
feature say something like that if
you're telling everyone that things are
going on sale Paulo should mention it
there next we have a content the content
is the main piece of the email it's
likely to contain some combination of
text and images depending on your chosen
layout you're going to want to find the
right layout and the right type of
content to achieve your goals for each
particular email and this is where your
messaging is showcased so be sure to use
a consistent tone then we have our call
to action this should mirror the goal of
the email all of your email component
should lead to this call to action that
you want your readers to take so what is
it that you really want your readers to
do or to get out of this email then we
have the from name so who is this email
from is it abarkment support or is it
the abarkment team or is it lauren the
abarkment CEO Oh what do you think is
going to connect with your users and
what supports the goal of the email for
example if this is an email about a new
feature or business channel we're going
into maybe the email should come from
the CEO or the director of product if
it's about some type of customer support
maybe it should come from the support
team or a particular member of the
support team and finally the from
address this is the email that's
displayed to the receiver when they
receive the email you'll want to send
your emails from a consistent address
that aligns with the purpose of the
email before you choose your from
address make sure to take into account
the goals of the email in the general
tone you're trying to set if this is a
more personal email maybe it should come
from Lauren at abarkment calm instead of
abarkment dot support do not respond at
apartment calm you have options now when
sending your emails you can send a
regular old email from Gmail or
something like that or you can choose an
email platform which most growing
companies choose to do these platforms
will vary depending on the needs of the
company so when deciding on an email
platform you'll want to consider the
volume of emails you're sending the cost
in features like automation and
segmentation there are a few different
platforms out there that are great if
you're just getting started that are
pretty cost effective likes in grid
HubSpot MailChimp and then there are
also more robust platforms that have
built in automation advanced
segmentation and lifecycle emails like
Marketo responses and ExactTarget
let's go to Greg to see what he has to
say about email marketing